For our product line review
we've had tons of features or
lot's of people who are building
really amazing products.
Everything about my language is
talking about like how do I make it so
the user feels like they're kicking ass.
because a lot of people like
who are great building stuff,
they're like they talk about features
like look what we have, look what
we're doing, look why this is awesome,
this is going to be really cool.
And it needs to be complete opposite,
where it needs to be like look we use
this, this is what's going to kick ass.
And so it's all about the language and
the features.
Like I can say you get 1,000 entries,
unlimited forms,
you get payment integration.
But that's just listing the features.
What I need to say is look, you don't
have to worry about data collection
anymore, everyone in your department is
going to have this installed on there.
You get to make money off of this.
Monetize like a couple of seconds,
instead of having to wait for paying
like thousands of dollars for someone to
build a custom Ecommerce site for you.
Beta test certain issues.
User management like all that stuff has
to be turned around when you're talking
about this feature.
So that took us a while to understand
like okay, the motivations on why people
want to be on certain plans and
making sure it got communicated.
You being on here, the reason
you're on here is because of this,
because it's all for you.
And that took a real sort of empathy
in terms of describing and sort
of a knack for copy that's a flipside
of how people think about things.
Because like entrepreneurs are really
good about talking about sells and
pitching their company and
all that stuff, but
a lot of times they don't realize like
the pitch you need to give is the pitch
that allows people to talk
about you to someone else.
It's like I use this and it's my secret
weapon, I'm sharing it with you now.
And I'm now, like your most interesting
person at the dinner able or
you gave this tip that makes you
look like the really awesome guy.
And so a lot of people just don't
even craft copy in a way that
can be disseminated that easily.
A lot of times they'll just use
weird slogans and taglines,
short phrases and stuff.
And I was like I can't
repeat that to someone and
have it make any coherent sense on
why you should use this service.